elle arrive au moins deux fois par
semaine remplie demandeurs d'asile ces
camionnettes blanches n'était pas là
avant la pandémie
elles sont le symbole d'un commerce du
désespoir qui s'est récemment développé
ça c'est nouveau on m'a dit que seven
viennent du sud des états unis
jetpack footswitch et la mairesse de
champlain dans l'état de new york le
village qui abrite le maroc
elle vient ici tous les jours et
constatent les migrants sont désormais
au coeur d'une industrie lucrative c'est
une crainte commerce un réseau de
beaucoup de personnes différentes et
tout le monde profitera financièrement
koffi est un demandeur d'asile africains
dès son arrivée aux états unis il est
parti directement floride pour monter à
bord de l'une de ces camionnettes ils
ont une place spécialement donc la voix
j'ai vu quatre voitures ça sous forme de
fonds
le chauffeur n'avait qu'une seule
condition et j'avais discuté du tout ça
indique était un crash ces sondes à
miami est devenue une des plaques
tournantes de la migration irrégulière
par le canada plusieurs des camionnettes
que l'on retrouve au chemin oxame par dc
on a appelé un passeur en prétextant
être migrants kurdes par match et this
is it hot ou go to work sam
mais est-ce légal on a posé la question
la grc leur réponse est sans équivoque
des particuliers qui facilite et
conseille les passages illégale à la
frontière peuvent en effet faire l'objet
d'accusations au canada
on a pris rendez vous avec un
propriétaire de camionnettes en se
présentant comme journaliste
il a accepté de nous rencontrer sans
caméra il nous dit avoir une grosse
demande
beaucoup énormément d'appels il ya
beaucoup d'haïtiens qui veulent aller au
canada
en une semaine je peux faire facilement
80 personnes il ya deux gars qui
travaillaient pour moi et maintenant ils
sont partis faire leurs
cet homme nous explique faire plusieurs
trajets par semaine
les gens y viennent d'un peu partout et
viennent tout exode loyaux indianapolis
la louisiane il gagne donc plusieurs
milliers de dollars à chaque voyage il
n'a jamais été embêté par la police
américaine
officiellement l'agencé américaine
responsable de la frontière assure tout
faire pour empêcher des passages
frontaliers illégaux même vers le canada
pourtant des sources nous ont dit le
contraire c'est ce qu'estime également
sept experts en immigration les
américains font nada 0 j'admire la
logique pourquoi à l'aube et les
ressources nécessaires pour empêcher le
flot vers la canada parce que l'objectif
de leur système c'est d'expulser ces
gens sont aveugles de façon volontaire
le gouvernement de justin trudeau a de
son côté refusé nos demandes d'entrevue
impossible donc de savoir si le canada
un plan pour déjouer ces passeurs et ce
commerce de plus en plus payant